digamos que tenemos mesas
a ver voy a dibujarla aquí tenemos una
mesa obviamente la estoy viendo desde
arriba y quiero acomodar personas en
esta mesa así que de los extremos puedo
poner una persona en este extremo y otra
persona en este extremo del lado largo
puedo acomodar dos personas por cada uno
de los lados largos de la mesa así que
si tengo una sola mesa puedo acomodar 1
2 3 4 5 6 6 personas
muy bien ahora observemos que pasa
cuando tengo dos mesas contiguas es
decir tengo la primer mesa
y ahora agregó una segunda mesa contigua
a la primera
y quiero ver cuánta gente nueva puedo
acomodar ahora en dos mesas es decir ya
tenía yo dos personas en los extremos de
la mesa y estos ya estaban sentados en
la primera mesa
y ahora puedo acomodar dos personas más
por cada lado largo de la segunda mesa
otra forma de verlo es que aquí tengo la
mesa número 1 que es esta que está aquí
y ahora esta es la mesa número 2
teniendo dos mesas puedo acomodar a 1 2
3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 10 personas
muy bien
hagámoslo ahora para tres misas
una mesa contigua tengo
la segunda mesa y contigua la segunda
tengo la tercer mesa
lo mismo en cada extremo de las mesas
puedo acomodar una persona
aquí están los que ya estaban en las
mesas
y puedo agregar nuevos a estas personas
en estos lados de la mesa y ahora
observemos cuántos tenemos tenemos 1 2 3
4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14
tenemos ahora 14 personas
hay algo que me gustaría llamar la
atención en qué es lo que está pasando
quiero fijarme en esta persona de la
mesa 1 si la que está en este extremo de
la mesa cuando yo agrego la segunda mesa
esta persona conserva su lugar en el
extremo de la mesa es este mismo que
está aquí entonces si vemos en realidad
los únicos lugares nuevos para acomodar
personas pues serán estos que están aquí
1 2 3 y 4
y si observamos nuestros números vemos
que de 6 pasamos a 10 es decir que
incrementamos en 4 y de 10 pasamos a 14
también incrementamos en 4 y lo cual
hace sentido cada vez que agregó una
mesa sólo puedo acomodar 4 personas
nuevas por lo que ya no será necesario
seguir haciendo diagramas como estos es
decir se agregó una mesa más estaré
agregando 4 personas y de 14 pasaré a 18
personas y se agregó una mesa más pasaré
de 18
a 22 personas
y se agregaron 4 personas
y así podré continuar y continuar y
continuar